hector thank you very much it is now 607
it has been nearly
three months since metro police
lieutenant eric lloyd died of
complications from covid 19.
among other things he was president of
the injured police officers fund
yesterday members met for the first time
without lloyd as their leader
the meeting focused on how the
organization plans to move forward
lieutenant lloyd's widow is also the
project director now we spoke with mindy
lloyd
the organization itself and the brothers
and sisters and
in blue they have been amazing
and they continue the work that they um
that they feel in their heart because
they they know that they have families
too
and it could be them i just
know i have huge shoes to fill
eric was a great man he had a huge heart
and such a big passion for this position
and he didn't care what his title was he
did everything that he could to support
our mission at the injured police
officer's fund to help those in need
the injured police officers fund is now
focusing on covet 19 prevention
and it's also trying to be more vocal
about the deadly reality of the pandemic